why hello
i didn't know you'd be there i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message and today is july
28th in the year 2021
in just a mere three days i will be
disappearing for a month
will the world be here when i get back
we'll find out
or we won't i don't know uh guys as
always do me a favor
subscribe to our videos tap the
notification bell share them
all that good stuff and yes we will
have content coming out throughout
august actually we've got a couple
interviews that i've been doing this
week
next week once i'm off the grid they're
all going to be devoted to calming down
not being crazy not letting politics get
to you how you can be healthier both
physically
and mentally how you cannot be so
obsessed with all the stuff online
we had discussed not doing anything for
august but that could really crush us
in the youtube algorithm and really
wreck the future
of the channel online which obviously we
didn't want to do that
that's by the way part of why i go off
the grid because these algorithms
keep us constantly obsessed with
everything and clicking and blah blah
blah
so we are going to only do one interview
a week and we've got some great
interviews
uh the first one next week will be with
eckhart tolle
all about just surviving this digital
madness we just taped it it's i mean
talking to that guy is really just like
as good as it gets
for an interviewer and just someone that
wants to find some
some peace on this earth and then we've
got some fitness stuff and some other
health stuff and
i think you're gonna you're gonna dig it
throughout the month but the point is
we're not gonna keep you there just
mashing buttons and clicking like
and all of that stuff guys we got three
stories for you today
the big january sixth insurrection
commission
uh took place yesterday there was
testimony
there was crying there were people
wearing diapers it was all
very very theatric so we're going to
show you some of that
just ridiculous i mean these democrats
crying it's just
so pathetic we will also juxtapose you
guys know i like the word juxtaposed we
will juxtapose
uh some of the images because we've all
seen the images of january 6. and look
some people
got in there somebody took a picture at
pelosi's desk
one person did get killed it happened to
be one of the people who went in it was
not a law enforcement officer there was
actually
a woman who uh ashley babbitt who was a
military
member uh she was the only person killed
that day nobody brought guns but
you know they've got their meme out
their meme is that this was the
trump-led insurrection uh aoc said that
we were only an
hour away from martial law she also
thought she was going to get raped that
day i mean these people are just
absolute clowns so we're going to show
you some of the stuff
from the commission yesterday it's just
bananas then speaking of
bananas this fouchy guy the infallible
pouchy
he has flip-flops so many times and i
saw a two-minute video yesterday on the
twitter
that is just the most spectacular
destruction of
every thing that anthony fauci has done
for the last year and a half
and not only that then we're going to
show you some video of uh joe biden
talking about vaccines and that you
won't have to wear masks anymore in
there now they're reversing on that i
mean they're just reversing
on absolutely everything because as
they're telling us the science is always
evolving so it's almost like you
shouldn't buy into everything they say
the second they say it
because we get new information and now
there's a study out of sweden showing
that the vaccines are not
nearly as effective as uh
as we thought so i'll just present some
information to you
and we uh source it so you can you know
figure out something for yourself and
then finally the border crisis down
south we haven't done
too much on the border here because i'm
usually you know dealing with all this
other nonsense
uh but it's bananas they're they've got
tons of people just basically walking
through the border half of them don't
have masks on if we're to believe that
we're in this
crazy pandemic they're not i assure you
they're not social distancing
and uh we're just letting them in it's
very odd why do we do that down there
but if
we don't have just like an open border
with canada even though i know a lot of
canadians
and shout out to you canadians who watch
this show i know there are many
freedom loving canadians especially in
western canada but i know that freedom
is spreading throughout
canada right now uh we don't have just
like an open door policy we don't just
let canadians walk in so why do we keep
letting all these people
walk in our southern border when often
they're not even from mexico they're
from other countries a lot of them are
from haiti they're from all over the
place and we just
kind of let them in and then we spread
them throughout the country and we're
supposed to be in the middle of a
pandemic
i'm starting to think something's rotten
in stink town you see what i'm saying
people
guys before i get to any of that i want
to talk to you about black rifle coffee
i'm drinking it right now you know black
rifle coffee is a veteran-owned coffee
company serving premium coffee
to people who love america veteran ceo
and founder evan hafer
spent over seven years on the ground
overseas with u.s special forces and as
a cia contractor
black rifle coffee company is
continually committed to supporting
veteran law enforcement and first
responder causes
this summer they'll invite you to enjoy
your coffee by that they don't mean just
the great taste of america's coffee but
the more places you drink it the passion
and adventure it fuels and inspires and
the entertainment
they serve along the way whether you're
brewing the perfect cup of pour over
before
kicking ass at work or cracking a can of
300 on your next back country mission
black rifle coffee company is here to
fuel your way wherever the summer takes
you
they import their high quality coffee
beans from all over the world and roast
five days a week at their facilities in
manchester tennessee and salt lake city
utah
the team at black rifle coffee is
continually researching and
experimenting with their new roasting
methods and coffee origins watch this
i'm going to take a sip right now
it's delicious purchase at
blackriflecoffee.com
reuben and use code ruben at checkout
for 20 off your first purchase and your
first coffee club order
fuel your summer with america's coffee
black rifle coffee
and now back to me okay so let me just
broadly say something about the january
6th insurrection that we're being told
about okay
a lot of people showed up at the capitol
some of them were violent and if you
broke the law
if you broke windows if you attacked
police officers if you damaged property
et cetera et cetera
i believe in laws i believe that we are
a country that needs the rule of law if
you don't have the rule of law you
really don't have anything i know that
sounds very trumpian right if you don't
have a border you don't have a country
i believe in the rule of law i know that
sounds really crazy you know
authoritarian right-wing stuff but if
anyone broke the law
that day you have to be dealt with you
have to be dealt with fairly i mean now
it seems like we've got people
that have been held without trial for
months and in solitary confinement and a
whole bunch of other stuff
but my preface to all of this is if you
broke the law that day
you know just as i would say in anything
else i would even go as far to say if
you were saying san francisco and you
stole a whole bunch of stuff
from a walgreens that you should be
criminally pers
uh prosecuted okay you know i'm a guy of
the law what can i tell you
um a lot of people did not break the law
that day a lot of people actually just
went to peacefully protest they went to
have their voices heard
they were not happy about the election
that is your god-given right as an
american
regardless of whatever you think the
truth related to the election may be
okay you're allowed to protest
uh the fact that they took their
protests to the seat of power
to the capital in dc as opposed to say
burning down random cities
attacking federal courthouses you know
assaulting people on the street you know
hunting down
people they disagree with you know
things that the black lives matter
people do and that the antifa people do
over two billion dollars worth of damage
in the last two years or so
uh the fact that they took it to the
seat of power is pretty good
by the way there are plenty of videos
and you've all probably seen them
because you are
online creatures not blue-pilled
mainstream zombies
where they're talking to law enforcement
there and law enforcement people are
saying yes you can go in just stay
peaceful
you know stay within the lines don't go
into these offices you can see videos
where they move barricades out of the
way
and then yes it did get out of control
so okay i think i've given you my
fair estimation of what happened that
day the bigger issue than what actually
happened that day in those few hours
where aoc was you know off-site and
claimed she thought she was going to get
killed and raped
she wasn't even there the bigger issue
is the way that the media and the
democrats have used january 6 to
basically stifle dissent make sure that
every republican or trump supporter or
conservative
is on some kind of list and feels that
they could get kicked off twitter and
youtube and everywhere else
if they just tweet something that goes
against the narrative that's really the
issue
uh because everyone knows that there is
nobody and and i want you to think about
this in your own life is there anyone
beyond the sort of media elite so like
the cnn types and then the democrat
elite the politicians
that's really talking about january 6th
that really is like yes this thing was
an
insurrection there were no plans to take
over the government right
you know we're an hour away from martial
law it's like no
that is complete fabrication like
everything else you do
these were people that were at at the
very least a little overzealous
some of them did obviously commit crimes
anyway the democrats and the media are
using this
as just this constant crudgell to paint
everyone that disagrees with them as a
violent extremist making sure it seems
like everyone that was there
was a white supremacist which is exactly
what they did at all the trump rallies
and everything else so they're having
the hearing okay
they're having the hearing much like we
had two sham impeachments they're having
their little
you know their little dog and pony show
and half the democrats are just crying
while they're up there because they're
so rattled by this thing that basically
took place for a couple hours
uh you know basically six months ago
here's
adam schiff because if
we're no longer committed to a peaceful
transfer of power after our elections
uh if our side doesn't win then god help
us
we deem elections illegitimate merely
because they didn't go our way
rather than trying to do better the next
time god help us
and if we're so driven by bigotry and
hate that we attack our fellow citizens
as traitors
if they're born another country or they
don't look like us
and
god help us but
i have faith
because of folks like you
thank you people who don't look like us
and other things happened and it was two
hours
and i made up a fake impeachment and i
did it twice
and i'm really horrible but
here's adam kinzinger i never expected a
day to be
quite as emotional for me as it has been
i've talked to
a number of you and gotten to know you
i think it's important to tell you right
now though
you guys may like individually feel a
little broken
you guys all talk about the effects you
have to deal with and
you know you talk about the impact of
that day
but you guys won
you guys helped
you know democracies are not defined
by our bad days
we're defined by how we come back from
bad bad days
how we take accountability for that
and for all the overheated rhetoric
surrounding this committee
our mission is very simple let's define
the truth
and it's to ensure accountability
thank you it's just because we've had a
bad day
and can i oh thank you and
we're just we're trying
okay these people are complete
ridiculous
actors they are theater actors and not
very good ones you know what we did
we went back all the way to may of 2020.
do you remember may of 2020
because here's what happened outside the
white house these are
antifa and blm protesters outside the
white house
insurrection you decide
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh wait that's the one we don't cry for
right no crying that's all right that's
all right no crying
yeah those are blm people those are
antifa people we've got some stills
right now we have some stills are some
of the
signs that they had up there the people
want blood uh
pretty sure they meant police blood
maybe trump's blood uh
as you can see these are not very happy
people these are angry people
insurrectionists revolutionaries people
that we should arrest
people that we should have a sham
hearing about strange
by the way according to the guardian 25
people
were killed in the blm george floyd
protests of 2020.
you remember you may remember you
probably don't actually officer david
doran who was one of the people killed
black police officer who was killed in
the line of duty somehow no rallies for
him
in the midst of that 25 people killed
in the rallies the blm antifa rallies
related to george wood
as i said before one person was killed
on january 6 and it happened to be
this woman ashley babbitt who was a
former member of the military
and she was shot dead by capitol police
this is all theater
this is all theater and it is designed
to then
get places like the adl and these other
activist organizations to then work with
the administration
okay to make sure that they can ban and
silence and censor
everyone who is dissenting on the big
tech platforms
uh that is one of the reasons that i
started locals it's one of the reasons
i've got some announcements starting on
on
friday when i get off the grid we're
going to fix this stuff
because these people they're out for
everybody they're out for everybody and
sorry kenzinger you pet republican he's
a kinzinger is a republican by the way
he's a pet republican that's what i call
them
the guys that go on msnbc so they can be
told they're they're nice people there's
a mitt romney a liz cheney you're a pet
and we pet you on the head and oh sit
sit sit oh you want to tweet
uh that's what they are i don't like
them and i don't like schiff and schiff
is just the worst you know he's a
congressman
here in california he's helped wreck
this state um
he's just a complete ineffectual
trying to be nice i was i decided not to
curse wasn't that nice i was trying to
be nice
um they're just they're just terrible
people and they're liars and their
actors and just know that
and then go ahead with your life and
everything will be okay uh but speaking
of liars and actors we got to talk about
fouchy because now fauci is coming out
and he's kinda into this idea that the
cdc
and remember the center for disease
control it doesn't set law it can give
recommendations
but people seem to think if the cdc says
something you have to do it
uh the cdc you know they give the basic
ideas guys this is what we're seeing
this is what we think you should do this
is sort of a mandate but you don't have
to do it it's not a law as far as i know
i'm just i'm just a simple guy
but cdc is sort of into this idea now
that if you've been
vaccinated you probably should still
wear a mask we've got the videotape
dr fauci the cdc is saying that this is
based on new
science new data showing that even those
who are vaccinated
can carry the virus with them they can
be contagious
this seems to contradict what we've been
told
that once you get vaccinated you're
protected well
in in some respects yes but what's
changed duty is the virus has changed
so when you have vaccinated people who
might have a breakthrough infection and
we know now as a fact
as a scientific fact that they can
transmit the virus to an uninfected
person
it's for that reason that the cdc made
the change in recommendation
and did just as you correctly stated
namely that if you are
vaccinated if you are an indoor setting
you should still wear a mask i hear you
saying it is based on science but
to many americans who are by now
pandemic weary
um do you understand why they may be
looking at this and we're hearing this
from some
from a number of americans saying well
why did why did the cdc
uh change the guidelines two months ago
were they
did they jump the gun when they did that
or they're asking you know why weren't
they more transparent
in the beginning people are asking these
kinds of questions those are reasonable
questions
judy but i think what we all need to
realizing we are dealing
with an evasive type of in a virus it
it evolves so that people need to
understand it
it's a it's a painful realization but
it's true
yeah the painful realization here
anthony
is that this thing does evolve and you
guys have flip-flopped every which way
and done roughly four trillion
things that have not helped uh two
interesting pieces before we show you
this incredible video of fouchy's
flip-flops
um when everybody was pushing the
vaccine a couple months back
were they saying was there any hint that
oh guys you're going to get the vaccine
and by the way
you'll probably still get covid you'll
still be able to get covered you'll
still be able to transmit covid
you're probably going to have to get
booster shots and by the way the whole
thing
keeps uh mutating and changing and
everything else
so we'll see what happens in six months
that's not really the way they did the
sale did they
actually the way they did the sale you
know i'm gonna switch something here
we're gonna do the biden video next all
right
the way they did the sale was basically
get the vaccine and you are good to go
okay and guess what we got video on that
too here's joe biden
on what happens when you get the vaccine
if you are
fully vaccinated you no longer need to
wear a mask
really joe because that's not what the
cdc is saying now that's not what
fouchy's saying now
so when you said that you know basically
two months ago
a month and a half ago why didn't you
say oh well unless the science changes
and morphs which by the way fauci's
saying science constantly changes and
morphs and we get new information which
of course that actually
is true i mean it's actually quite
extraordinary so now we're going to show
you
a two-minute video this went bananas
viral on
twitter yesterday these are just
incredible
back and forth compilations of fouchy
flip-flopping take a look
people should not be walking around with
masks let me just state
for the record that masks are not
theater
wearing a mask might make people feel a
little bit better and masks are
protective
and but it's not providing the perfect
protection that people think
that it is there has not been any
indication
that putting a mask on and wearing a
mask for a considerable period of time
has any deleterious effects there are
unintended consequences people keep
fiddling with the mask and they keep
touching their face
and can you get some schmutz sort of
staying inside there of course
you do not need to wear a mask indoors
if in fact
you've been vaccinated good that you're
vaccinated but in a situation
where you have people indoors
particularly crowded you should wear a
mask
so even if you are vaccinated you should
wear a mask if in fact you are
vaccinated
fully vaccinated you are protected and
you do not need to wear a mask outdoors
or indoors
when the children go out into the
community you want them to continue to
wear masks you know if you look at
children outside particularly when
they're with the family uh
walking down the street playing a game
or what have you don't have to wear
a mask the the the pediatric the academy
of pediatric
actually makes that recommendation that
children should be wearing masks
uh from two years old onward and you
you're asking now if
your child is a member of your household
can you walk outdoors
with your child without a mask according
to that chart
the answer is yes but the child can't
not to beat it
and beat it to death yes yes because now
the cdc says
i mean i think i've got this right one
mask is better than zero masks
two masks is better than one mask but
you don't have to have double masks
is that right i mean you know it became
clear that cloth coverings
that you didn't have to buy in a store
that you could make yourself
were adequate and then you wanted to fit
better so one of the ways you could do
it if you would like to
is put a cloth mask over which actually
here and here and here where you could
get leakage in
is much better contained are you a
double master dr fauci
look like you are we should have played
the looney tunes theme song in the
background of that thing i mean tell me
that is not
absolutely incredible and are you going
to tell me also
that oh the science was changing the
whole time in that last year and a half
while he was doing that
that you know when you touch your face
more because the mask that actually
causes a problem is that not a problem
anymore now that they want masks on us
again
and he also says mask might make you
feel better right
because they don't do anything now mask
again even though you're vaccinated
anthony fauci if you're watching this
show i am but a humble youtuber
but i have a recommendation for you
retire
go away just disappear nobody's going to
come looking for you we don't
care where you go go down to florida
where
they've got descent is not masking
people because i have no doubt
that fauci is not masking himself
privately and at his dinners
uh fauci by the way as you probably know
is the highest
paid person in the entire federal
government he makes over 400 000
a year i have no doubt that he's also
making all sorts of money from
investments related
to all vaccines like there's just no
doubt that all of that stuff
is part of this um i don't know how you
can trust that guy
how can you trust that guy how can you
be someone
who has some semblance of a functioning
brain
and at this point trust what that guy
says or
trust when joe biden says if you're
vaccinated you don't have to wear a mask
now you do have to wear a mask so did
joe biden or his handlers did nobody
have
an inkling that perhaps the virus was
going to mutate that perhaps there was
going to be a variant and everything
else
and now there's some really
extraordinary stuff so a swiss
policy research group has analyzed some
data coming out of israel and this is
really really incredible stuff so let's
let's listen to this it's three bullet
points it's really extraordinary
actually
the latest data from israel which has
primarily used the pfizer
mrna vaccine indicates that vaccine
effectiveness
against delta coronavirus infection and
symptomatic
disease has dropped from about 95
percent
to 40 percent whereas effectiveness
against hospitalization and severe
disease for example
low blood oxygen levels remains at 80 to
90 percent
c chart above come back to me for one
second so in essence what they're saying
there
is uh if you're going to get the milder
version
of the delta variant that it could help
a little bit
but that's not the way any of this was
sold was any of this
sold that if you get vaccinated that
you'll just get a milder thing i know
that's the meme out now that you're just
going to get a milder version that's
still while you should do it but it's
going to be
you know they told us originally 95
effective now they're telling us
that in that case it's actually only 40
effective all right it continues
the israeli data shown above indicates
that effectiveness against infection
and mild symptoms decreases rapidly
over time and reaches near zero levels
at about half a year so if you have the
vaccine after about a half a year it's
completely worthless
most likely this is because coveted
vaccines do not achieve
mucosal immunity in contrast to natural
infection
and serum antibody levels i.e antibodies
in the blood decrease within months c
chart below
so what they're saying there is you
would have a better situation
for yourself if you actually got covid
which many many people did
and then you had natural immunities that
would be better than the vaccine okay
and then finally there's some
interesting stuff here thus the false
premise
of a very high protection against
symptomatic infection
found during the official vaccine trials
was simply based on very high
short-term serum antibody levels
mimicking mucosal immunity
conceivably the pharmaceutical companies
may have even
known that this was just a very
lucrative lucrative
flash in the pan and not a lasting
protective effect
really think about that for one second
what this swiss
study which is based on israeli data is
saying i mean this this
last part there is that's pretty
inflammatory what they're saying is they
did these trials for such a short period
of time that it's very possible
that pfizer and the other companies knew
that they didn't know what was going to
happen after this short test period
that eventually you'd need more and more
boosters and why would they want that
do you think and again i'm not an
economist
or a math a magician or a scientist but
do you think it's possible
that these vaccine companies that are
making a ton of money right now
ton of money billions and billions and
billions of dollars that they might have
been like oh you know let's just test
this short term it'll kind of look good
and then when it doesn't look good or if
it starts petering out which is exactly
what's happening right now oh we'll
start doing booster shots how about a
monthly subscription right everybody
loves subscription these days you just
put your credit card in once you don't
have to think about it
how about a monthly subscription to
pfizer or a monthly
a monthly subscription to johnson
johnson or whatever else it is
so what do you do with that information
what do you do with that information
they tell you one thing a month ago
they completely flip on it we just
showed you a year and a half worth
of fouchy flipping i personally
once again would say that if you want to
get vaccinated you should get vaccinated
i would also say that eating right and
doing exercise and probably getting a
little bit of sun
and you know trying to be around
relatively healthy people and if you
want to wear a mask that's fine and all
that stuff
maybe it has a little something to do
with personal responsibility
and i would also say i tweeted this out
this morning
i am far more concerned about the mind
virus
going around right now than i am about
the covid virus and that's not to
diminish any of the realities around
kovid
but the mind virus that somehow these
government officials care about us
that these scientists who flip and flop
care about us that the people who lock
us in our houses and demand we wear
masks
and don't care that people are out of
work and depressed and
you know rates of alcoholism are going
through the roof and and suicide in
young people and all those things
perhaps they aren't the ones that really
care about us do you think the ones who
keep you in your house and keep you out
of work
really care about us on top of the fact
that for a bunch of people who are
really concerned about health
they don't seem to mind that the
president has old person syndrome
i'm starting to see a trend here all
right let's move on to the third story
i'll do this one a little briefly the
border i haven't done much on the border
as i mentioned at the top
because there's just been so much going
on but we do have an absolute
border crisis now let's remember when
donald trump was president
there was a border crisis and trump was
putting kids in cages and it was very
evil all of the things that were
happening and it was racist and if you
believed in a border
uh you're a racist and a bigot most
likely a nazi
all of that good stuff uh then biden
starts putting kids in cages aoc doesn't
go to the border to
you know have her little photo shoot
kamala harris it took her months to get
down there and she only went because
trump went down
we see kids literally in cages you've
all seen the images and they've got the
that sort of metallic wrapping on them
and we're told that we have to socially
distance and wear masks but then they've
got
cages that are that are over packed by
about 800 percent
in some cases kids on top of each other
nobody's wearing masks et cetera et
cetera
well now there is just an extraordinary
amount of people just literally walking
through the border we've got some video
on it but first
quote from the blaze catch and release
is alive and well
under the biden administration as 50 000
migrants who crossed into the southern
border illegally
have been released into the u.s without
a court date
though migrants are told to report to an
ice officer after they are released from
detention
only 13 have done so axios reported on
tuesday
the report comes as record numbers of
migrants are seeking
illegal entry into the united states
southwest land border
encounters have been steadily increasing
since president joe biden assumed office
in january with 188
000 encounters reported in june the
highest number
in decades now this is really incredible
stuff
so about 50 000 people have just
basically wandered into the united
states
and been told hey could you check in
with the nice guy uh maybe next week
you know go say hi to your friends and
family get settled then could you do
that would you would you
you're not going to believe it guys a
whole bunch of them most of them are not
doing that now
let's put aside borders for a second
let's just jump back to the covid
situation
if we are to believe that this is the
thing killing everybody and grandma's
dead and everyone she knows is dead and
children and everything and we've got to
shut down everything
do you think that we should be just
letting people wander in from other
countries into the country into the
country right now even if you're the
most open border
lefty nut bag do you think that right
now relative to
the pandemic do you think that perhaps
this wouldn't be the time for that
uh but yes they are literally just
wandering in with mask and without and
often with no social distancing
uh and we've got some video here this is
former ice director
and he is not this is the former ice
director he is not happy with joe biden
right now this is from fox news take a
look northern border
we have with canada is still closed
because of covet
and the southern border is wide open and
you're right i mean
ice has already had 7 500 positive
covenant cases
run through their system right now as
we're speaking
they have nearly 1200 active cases in
custody right now
that came across that border so and what
really scares me
is in nearly 300 000 got aways this year
those who escaped apprehension
how many of them had coleman and and we
already know
the u.s government on purpose has
released hundreds of
covent positive people into the interior
by either
buying a bus ticket or a plane ticket
and releasing them into the interior
united states
this is this is simply incompetence at
the highest level
at the same time they're talking about
americans masking up
they're talking about door-to-door
vaccinations the u.s citizens being held
accountable to coven but the southwest
border is wide open
okay so tom homan that is the former
director of ice
okay and he is saying some incredibly
damaging stuff right now now not only do
we have 1200 people right now
that are migrants trying to walk in who
have coveted so how many
you know weren't we worried remember a
couple months back we were very worried
about covid in prison so what did we
have to do we had to open up the prisons
right that was one of the many
brilliant progressive policies so that
means we have 12 000 people
in the system at the southern border
right now who have coveted how many
people have they spread it to
do we know about that but then he's
telling us
we know we have covered positive
patients that are being put on buses and
planes
and sent throughout the country again
forget the border thing right because i
guess
if you talk about the border you're
automatically a racist personally at
this point i would almost be for
shutting down the borders
all together if there was ever a time to
do it and be like guys we have some
internal stuff we have to deal with
nobody can come over
today you know like when you're a kid
and you want your friend to come over
mom and dad are fighting it's like no
not today like we got to deal with some
family stuff today
and maybe you can come over and you know
play sega genesis tomorrow something
like that
uh this is the idiotic situation we're
being put in the same people who want
open borders are the same people who are
telling us we have to shut down the
economy and they're the same people who
want people
who have kovid who are often walking
into this country
not even from the country that they're
walking in from right because they're
usually haitian refugees and a whole
bunch of other stuff
and other south american countries and
they don't have masks on
don't believe me here's some video
foreign
i don't mean to be a dick i don't mean
to be a racist white supremacist but how
about we just say those people hey guys
sorry not today
uh you're not social distancing okay a
lot of you aren't wearing masks
we got some stuff we need to deal with
and you can't come in today but that's
not what we're doing
we're basically letting these people
walk in and then as the former ice
director said we're busting them all
over the place
this is an extraordinary stat how about
this they've offered
almost everyone that comes in to the
country these people they've offered
them
vaccines over 30 percent have refused
the vaccine
that's from axios now again if we're to
believe that this pandemic is going to
cause the collapse of western society
then what should we do with those people
shouldn't we say okay sorry at the very
minimum
we'll figure out your refugee status and
if you're under threat and everything
else and i get it you want to come to
america
and i know that half the country you
know believes that america is an evil
racist place and
that's an awful lot of brown skinned
people over there trying to come to
america they must be very confused
but you know the very minimum
requirement is you have to take the
vaccine
and 30 of them are saying no and we
don't do anything about it
you get it you get it guys part two of
my interview
with congressman jim jordan it's all
about big tech it's about government
dysfunction
it's about this january 6 insurrection
hearing which nancy pelosi by the way
stopped jim jordan from being on the
commission
because she only wants people that are
hysterically crying apparently
so part two of my interview with jim
jordan is up right now part one
of my interview with uh the fastest
talking jew on the internet ben shapiro
is up the full episodes of both of those
are up right now at rubinport.locals.com
and it's absolutely ad free
and early and uh this friday is the big
day
i'm gonna be doing a two hour at least a
two hour maybe more
at least a two hour live extravaganza
as i prepare to go off the grid we will
be announcing my new book
which i'm just so psyched uh to show you
the cover
and the pre-sale will begin that day if
you are a member of our reuben report
community at rubenport.locals.com you
can get a signed and numbered copy every
single member
of our locals community if you buy it
that day you will get the signed and
numbered copy
and then if you are not a member if you
buy it on day one
you can get a signed copy but it will
not be numbered and if i have to sign
ten thousand
uh books before going off the grid i
will gladly sign ten thousand books that
would be
absolutely my pleasure so that's what
i'm doing on friday and then we've got a
big announcement related to locals maybe
some other things there's a few things
cracking right now
and then i disappear for a month and uh
good luck to you so
okay see you tomorrow